Shiran Yaroslavsky, how are you?
Good good. How are you doing?
I am fantastic.
But first I want to hear
you're just around
you said Yellowstone,
making your way to Oregon
with a laptop on your back in your bag
as a digital nomad
for the next couple of weeks, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So my story is,
just for a bit of background,
I relocated to the US in last November.
And I was planning to explore the US,
and then covid hit us
and everything is in lock down.
And I live in the Bay Area.
So I'm waiting for my hairdresser
for five months now.
So, I'm like, we were working from home
and we're working for so many hours.
And we just decided,
my husband and me,
just to pack our stuff
and just go and explore the US a bit.
So, I'm now working a lot,
but also had the pleasure
to enjoy Yellowstone,
or Grand Teton, now Oregon.
So how does it work?
Do you actually literally
have your laptop in your bag
as you drive around
and whenever you get to stop somewhere,
you do the work and then you get to travel
and see some nice views
and different hikes?
Yeah. So, usually we choose an Airbnb
with very good Internet.
Yeah.
This is number one.
And then we try to,
if we manage to finish the day a bit early,
then we manage to hike a bit
and see, explore the area,
but if not only just the weekend
is amazing.
You get to see really amazing sceneries
these days.
And there is no
so much people around.
Right right. This is the perfect time.
Shiran, that's amazing.
So, I want to go back to your journey.
Lawyer, Jolt, so many different companies
along the way.
And all of a sudden,
I just love personally Jolt,
Roei and Nadav are such great people.
And now, most recently, the CEO
and co-founder of Cassiopeia Tech,
probably the most relevant thing
I've heard in the covid age.
But you didn't start this startup
during the covid time.
You started it a while back.
So, tell me a little bit
about what Cassiopeia is
and the journey that took you
to create it.
Sure. So, my background
is in product management.
I led product teams in Israeli tech,
in small companies, large companies.
I also led the product management course
at Jolt, as you mentioned.
It was amazing to just teach
other product managers
about the practices and methods.
You were actually a teacher
for a course, right?
For one of the courses that they offer?
Yeah, I was a moderator
of one of the courses.
Yeah, it was amazing.
And as you mentioned, so my training is in
I'm a lawyer by training.
So, I hold a bachelor
and master degree in law.
And so, yeah, this was in another life.
And when I was working
as a product manager,
me and a few other friends
were gathering and thinking
about how we can use technology
to improve workplace environment.
And we were very passionate about that.
And because of personal experience we had, thought about -
Tell me about that specifically.
Why change the workplace environment now?
And what year are we talking about?
So, we started it when I was,
when I think it was 2017
when I'm still was working
and we were-
No covid yet.
No covid. No. Not yet.
And we were exploring about
how we can use technology
to just empower managers
to improve workplace environment.
And we realized that with our background
and our knowledge,
we can create a technology
that can analyze
different communication patterns.
So data like who sent to whom and when,
no text involved,
and just provide insights
about team behavior.
But what bothered you about
the way that things were happening?
Because in tech, it's all about efficiency
and productivity.
What was wrong with the way
that things were happening in 2017
that you felt like you had to go
and think of ways
to improve the workplace?
Yeah. I think in 2017,
so we had our own personal experience.
Some of the co-founders
experienced exclusion,
or aggressive behavior, and we felt,
and 2017 also, the MeToo just exploded.
There are some ... cases in Israel
about sexual harassment in the workplace
that was also very,
in the day to day talk, I would say.
And this is something
that really bothers us,
and we thought about
how come we are so data driven
about everything in our life,
but when it comes to people,
experiences in the workplace,
we are just about some
just using some kind of sense-
- Our intuition
Or if we hear some rumors about it,
we are not data driven at all.
So, we thought how we can use
our technology, our experience
in order to help managers to do it better.
So, okay. So, what are some of the things
that you're actually using this data for
and how does it actually work practically?
I'm assuming that there were
dramatic changes from the way
that your solution was adapted in 2019
versus 2020, and we'll get to that.
But first, take me back to 2019.
We're in the workplace.
You go to meetings.
You have, you do different projects.
You send different emails.
Where does Cassiopeia
go into this whole pipeline of work?
Yeah. So, what we do
we just gather the data from email,
from Slacks, the chat platform,
also Microsoft Team, from Calendar,
and from the video platform.
And we just take the data, as I mentioned,
just the metadata.
So, data like, who sent to whom and when.
It takes between 10 to 15 minutes
to finish the technical onboarding,
and that's it.
And then we are just ready to go
sending weekly email reports to managers
with the most fervent insights for them
for this week.
So, give me examples of some insights
that I might be getting as a manager
if I'm leading a team of engineers
or product managers in a startup.
So, what are some things
that I would be getting
in my weekly summary?
Yeah. So, it really depends on you
as a manager.
So, part of the onboarding process,
you as a manager,
would be able to customize your report.
Basically decide what kind of insights
are more relevant for you,
what you would like to see
in your report.
But there is different insights
about collaboration.
For example,
collaboration within your team,
but also between teams.
If there is interrupting collaboration
between two teams,
you would know about it, for example.
About new employees,
onboarding new employees these days
is extremely challenging.
- Yeah.
So, a lot of insights about that.
So, for example, if we see
new employees in certain departments
that are less connected
compared to their teammates,
are less engaged
so we also will highlight it for managers
to just for them to be aware
that they need to provide more support
for these employees.
So, a lot about that.
Communication.
How to optimize our communication
within the company.
So, a lot of things that basically
every team needs these days.
I mean it sounds to me like
what you are opening up here
is this opportunity where
if I'm the CEO of a company
I can come and say,
Well, the culture that I want to have
in my company is I want people
to be communicating very efficiently.
So I'm expecting them to be on Slack
and answer promptly to others.
I'm expecting them
to finish their meetings on time
and not schedule back to back.
If I'm setting these cultural guidelines
and all of a sudden,
I can come in and see,
Okay, what's actually happening
in my 1,000 person organization?
Are people actually having
like six hour meetings a day
instead of just doing deep dives?
Maybe we have to teach people
how to have better meetings
or be more efficient
in their Slack communication.
So, that sounds hugely relevant.
But how did you deal with the fact that
a lot of the meetings don't take place
over a video or over Slack?
A lot of them are,
let's go to the water fountain
and speak next to the
like we do in school.
Yeah. So, we're working mostly with teams
that are working remotely.
So their almost all communication is online.
And when we are talking to you remotely,
there is the reason
it's so relevant these days,
is that when you are talking to you remotely,
there is what they're assigning
different ways and different variations.
But they just describe that
as a manager, a remote manager,
you're basically working
with a smaller data set.
So, you don't have
all these small data points
you used to have in the office.
You don't see how people engage,
with whom they're drinking coffee with,
if they're smiling during the day.
You don't have it anymore.
And so, as a remote leader,
there is a gap here that was created.
And what we do at Cassiopeia,
we are helping them to close that gap.
Just providing them the insights they need
to get a better sense
of their team dynamics
and spot some issues in a timely manner.
So, yeah. This is what ...
Okay. So, now we've reached 2020,
and the world has basically
turned upside down.
Every company that tried
to remain a social company in the office
is forced into this remote environment.
I was onboarded into Hippo insurance
as a remote employee.
So, I never actually met my manager
face to face, even though we often are
one mile away from each other.
But I think that I had a privilege
in having this introduction
into this remote work
having been onboarded back in mid-March
right when this all started.
And I got to see
Okay. What are some of the challenges
of onboarding?
And I have to say that Hippo
did a fantastic job with that.
But I can see
why it could be so challenging.
So, what has changed
in terms of Cassiopeia
over the last six months or so
since covid began?
Yeah. So as I mentioned,
at Cassiopeia, we were providing insights
about team behavior.
And in 2019 we were focusing
on providing more insights
about non-inclusive behavior.
So, more about aggressive behavior
and exclusion.
We worked with large companies,
mostly in the US and UK.
And when covid hit,
two of our customers
reached out to us and told us,
"This whole remote work thing
is really challenging for us.
Most of our managers
are not used to lead people remotely.
What can you do to help?"
And this just started this cycle,
and I will save you the details,
but just to make the long story short,
we decided to use our technology,
Cassiopeia's technology,
to empower remote leaders.
And yeah, basically we have the privilege,
and I'm very grateful for it,
to empower so many amazing leaders
and managers these days. So, yeah.
That's fantastic.
Talk to me a little bit
about the onboarding process.
I'm always curious about that.
So, you have this great platform.
Basically, every single company
in the world is now a relevant customer
for your platform.
What's your strategy?
Like you're in March. You realize that,
okay, this is my time to put on the gas.
Like, let's double down and get there.
What do you do as the CEO
to make that happen?
Yeah.
So, first of all,
to understand who is our early adopters,
and we are working mostly
with tech companies in the UK, in the US,
and we're working very closely with,
usually with R&D.
So the VP of R&D, or the VP engineering,
the of VP product, or the CTO.
Why is that?
Why more of the technical side?
I would actually imagine
that it would be more of the sales side,
or more of the product management part
of the company.
Yeah. So, also product.
We have also product teams.
But the reason that we are working
very closely with R&D and product
is that usually what we are,
the kind of insights we provide
about collaboration,
about communication,
really affect directly
on their performance.
And it's really crucial.
And also, there's a lot of challenges
working remotely
for R&D and product teams.
They need to collaborate
all the time and be synchronized.
So, there is a lot of value
that these teams just get
from using Cassiopeia.
And also, it's usually, and to be
very direct and open about it.
Usually this is the kind of teams
that are also very powerful
within the company.
So, if they want to use the tool
it's easy for them to buy it.
So, yeah.
So, part of the strategy then
is to go to these early adopters,
these teams that have the influence
within the company
and go to this R&D manager,
have them adopt within the team.
Hopefully have this then spread out
inside of the corporation
and that way you're actually getting
also exposed to different segments
of the company
that might not be incentivized
from day zero
to go into your platform, right?
Yeah.
That's so so cool.
So, three years down the line,
why are you still doing this?
What's up ahead?
I mean, what gets you really excited
about Cassiopeia today?
Yeah. So, I quit my job two years ago
to just lead Cassiopeia full time.
And it's basically the best ride I had.
So, I think you can learn so much
as a founder,
but also, I think, what I can say is that,
when you're very connected
to your mission and very passionate
about what you're doing,
and also doing it with amazing people,
basically, it's the ideal situation
for me as a person.
So, I get a chance to work
with amazing people,
doing amazing things,
build amazing products.
So yeah, this is why I keep doing it.
And where are we headed in terms
of remote work, collaboration?
Do you expect that managers
are gonna have even more tools
than what we have today?
And is this going to somewhat also
adversely affect the personal relationship
between a manager and their employees?
Because I'm imagining
the more data they have in regards to,
if my manager knows
my promptness to communicate on Slack
and whether I'm smiling or not,
that could detach a little bit
from her mission
to personally get to know me,
but more base her assumption
of my behavior
based on the analytics that you provide.
Yeah.
So, I would say that
what we see is a trend here.
And I think it's extremely interesting
that if you think about how companies
used to know or understand their culture,
or identify problems in their dynamics
in a timely manner.
What we used to do is as companies,
in the beginning,
we performed some kind of survey.
Endless surveys. I was just about to say.
In the Army, every two minutes
I had a survey to fill out.
Exactly. So you know
what I'm talking about.
Usually, it's some kind of external,
was external consultant
doing some surveys.
And this was the first stage, right?
And then the second stage
was survey softwares,
like Culture Amp and Peakon.
So, companies can do it in-house.
Right.
And both stages are more designed
for HR people,
human resource people.
And this was great.
And then the next stage
was using more advanced data.
So, data like the network analysis things
that we are doing.
More advanced data also for software
that are designed for HR and
people analytics. People persons.
So, you can see a very complex dashboard
with a lot of graphs,
and you need to really dig into the data
to get what you need.
And now, these days,
what we notice is that there is,
now we are getting to the last stage
which is more people analytics platforms
that are designed for managers.
So, because almost all communication
shifted to online,
there is more power for people analytics,
for technologies that use
this information to get more insights.
Also, managers are expected
to be more responsible
for an employee's experience,
as you mentioned.
And definitely there is a need for it,
because the work is so dynamic
and there is so many challenges.
You can't really allow yourself
as a manager just to use this survey
once in a year or something like that
to get to understand
your team dynamic better.
It doesn't make sense
in today's atmosphere.
So, this is what we are getting into.
Some people analytics solution
that are more designed for managers.
This is what we do at Cassiopeia.
And the employees
have no problem with this, right?
They're installing the software
that basically allows their managers
to get analytics based on their behavior.
Is there any pushback from that,
or do they just accept it?
Yeah. So, you're touching
really crucial points.
So, when you're using data
there is a lot of power there.
There is also a great responsibility.
And there is a big question
about how to use this data.
And what we do at Cassiopeia,
we provide insights on the team level,
or a subgroup level,
such as new employees.
But we won't show, for example,
that Dan is not talking that much
with John this week, for example.
So, we are not gonna show any analytics
that the manager is not aware of
about specific individuals
because we want to make sure
that people feel comfortable
using the platform.
And I think this is, again,
one of the most fascinating examples
that we're seeing more and more
in the past 10 years or so,
that we have the data,
we have the insights.
We're not allowing ourselves to know them.
And these are insights
that will make the workplace better.
If the manager did know
that Dan and Hila
are not speaking to each other
even though they're on the same team,
then they could take some action
to help correct that.
But obviously, the drawbacks
of having them be adversely affected
by that knowledge
and feeling that it's no longer
a safe space for them to operate,
that is a big problem.
Shiran, right before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most important question,
and I'm gonna put you on the spot once.
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Wow. This is I think,
it's the most difficult question.
And it's the most fun one.
I know. I know. I know.
But it's so hard. Okay, I will try.
I think the first one
will be a problem solver.
I'm really passionate about
solving problems
and maybe it's part of the reason why
I'm an entrepreneur.
So, definitely this is my first word.
The second word,
and I'm gonna cheat a bit,
but I think it's about
more pushing the limits.
Everybody is cheating on this thing.
I know. I know. It's so tempting.
But I think it's about pushing the limits
on a personal level,
but also on a business level.
I deeply feel that this is the only way
to really to develop our self
and to get to new places
as business and people.
So I, for example, I pushed myself
a few years ago.
I decided to run a full marathon.
And this was my first time.
And this was an amazing experience.
So, I really try in my day to day.
I love it. Which marathon was this?
Tel Aviv.
The Tel Aviv marathon. Amazing.
I planned to do the one in ...
but it got cancelled.
I actually, I signed up
for the Eilat marathon of 2017.
And only when I got there I realized
that I signed up to run on dunes
instead of a nice road.
Much harder.
It was an interesting experience
to say the least.
I'm still doing exercises
to relieve the tension,
but it was a good experience
no matter what.
Shiran, very lasting thing.
One advice you would give yourself.
We didn't even talk about this transition
from being a lawyer
and you were dealing with IP stuff
to being a product manager
and then an entrepreneur.
It doesn't sound like
the natural transition
for a lot of entrepreneurs
and a lot of product managers.
What is a piece of advice
that you would now go back
to the Hebrew University
where you were studying
and give yourself,
"Shiran, this is my two cents
from the future"
Wow.
This one might even be harder
than the three words.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
You're really pushing my limits here.
So I would say keep an open mind.
There's so many amazing things,
and I was sure that
I'm gonna be a lawyer or a judge
and this was my purpose in life.
And I discovered there is amazing things,
other amazing things,
that are a better fit for me.
So, just to keep to be open minded
about opportunities,
and to just keep learning,
I think, this is the main thing.
I love it.
Shiran, toda raba.
Enjoy Yellowstone. Enjoy Oregon.
And I love what you're doing there.
And I can't wait to share this
with the world.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
Bye bye.